let's go um let's go next to Harry from
Columbus Ohio Harry welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
David it's excellent to be talking to
you can you hear me all right I can't
hear you
thank you
um first I wanted to mention that you
said on a recent bonus show that you
wanted to buy some sort of sign for the
back of your car to talk to other
drivers and this is a fantasy I've had
as well
um but I would heavily advise against it
because I cannot think of a faster way
to get shot on the freeway
so definitely definitely don't buy that
if applications available please yeah my
my idea was you know the particularly
the texting and driving is such a
Scourge to society
from miles away on the highway you know
you see someone going 10 under in the
fast lane you know they're on a phone
and so I have this fantasy that as I
unfortunately have to pass them on the
right because they give me no choice you
get behind you know it's like they don't
even know how to use a highway as I pass
them on the right
I would have in my window I would just
pull up next to them and have this led
sign that would I could like type with a
keyboard or something and it would say
get off your phone get out of the fast
lane and that they would learn I'm
acting like an idiot and then they would
move over and everything would be great
but you're probably right that it
wouldn't really work out in that way
I imagine you know people would buy
these signs and there'd be like sort of
you know a race war or a racing war
between getting in front of each other
to swap messages like no you turn this
no you're doing that well I think it
would be effective on the side window as
much as in the back windshield you know
okay so to my real question so do you
have any sort of advice for somebody who
is currently at no reading of books I I
never really got into reading in high
school I was into Reddit into reading
news articles but like do you have any
sort of advice for like how to get
started in Reading because when I try to
sit down it sounds like the issue is
because you haven't regularly been
reading for a while you wouldn't even
really know where to start in terms of
what types of books you would enjoy
yeah I mean that's a good way of putting
it sure okay what topics are generally
interesting to you or what what movies
or TV shows or have you seen a document
documentary that that you liked what
sort of things are you into
I think the main thing is that I don't
want it to be a waste of time right like
I already I have such such little time I
wanted to be books where I'm taking in
the maximum amount of learning about um
I I think recent American political
history would probably be like the
greatest interest to me just like okay
you know
and your recommendations about because I
don't read those types of books at all
so my suggestion would be go to a
website like Goodreads and then just
search through some of the
recommendations and the highest rated
stuff I'm sure you'll find things that
are interesting to you
well you don't have any sort of
recommendations for like any yeah like
what what types of maybe authors in
general to look for maybe
for hello
okay
we just lost them okay I I don't read
that genre so I don't know but there
will absolutely be recommendations I
would I would consider checking out
Goodreads okay let's go to Daniel from
Maine Daniel from Maine welcome to the
program what's on your mind today and I
see that you are self-muted if you
unmute yourself you will be able to talk
to me Daniel from Maine welcome
you hear me yes
excellent uh first time caller uh I'm
actually shocked I was called on uh I'm
as shocked as you are to be honest
excellent uh so I've actually been a
viewer for a really long time
um about 10 years now actually so pretty
crazy yeah I started watching when you
still had Lewis on the show I saw Lewis
last night you know we played we went to
trivia and we were second to last
unfortunately
oh okay well that's that's pretty cool
uh anyways so I guess my question today
is what I guess how do you keep yourself
from not going insane with with what you
do
um you know I
when I watch you break down clips of
these insane you know Mega Republicans
and you know spouting their nonsense on
Fox News and stuff like almost sometimes
like I like hearing your input on those
things but when you replay the clips
before you give your input it's almost
like sometimes sometimes I can't even
listen to what these people have to say
like it's almost it makes me so sick
sometimes that like sometimes I fast
forward
even their Clips just so I can hear what
you have to say about it it's just that
nauseating you know what I mean like
well listen it's two things it's
basically two things one I am to some
degree desensitized by the insanity and
I I admit that it's not a good thing but
when you're exposed to this type of
insanity for a long time there's a
normalization that takes place and I'm
working against it but I know that I'm
desensitized to it to a degree and then
number two
um I I do think that taking a break from
this every single week and then longer
breaks every few months is important and
so when I'm done producing the Friday
show I don't even look at News until I
start prepping the Monday show so
there's like multiple days there where
people will say to me did you see this
did you see that I don't because I'm not
even paying attention to the news on
those days so I think scheduling that
and sticking to it is really important
okay yeah I I mean I guess that's just
all it's you know for a viewer like me
it's you know I can I can only take so
much per day before I have to like
literally shut it off because it's just
so just Bonkers like I totally
understand that I completely understand
that dude nothing no shame in that you
know yeah you'll play a Herschel Walker
clip and it's like I feel like I can
only sit through 15 seconds because it's
just so unbelievable no those are those
are pretty wacky I don't blame you there
my friend yeah all right uh I think
that's all okay thank you so much for
the call very much appreciate it uh
extremely powerful powerful stuff